Well, I don't feel anything there at all
when I
hit as hard as I could and I think Well, at least a
few relays will definitely drag
[music]
I left not knowing the situation in
Mariupol, they said different things, shelling, you wo
n't get there, don't try, it's better to go to
Russia, it will be better for you, it will be
safer there  and calmer, but I had the
intention of going to Ukraine and
was very afraid and probably would
like them to have such protection,
to make a light bulletproof vest, the main
task of which is to protect the child during
evacuation, protection, first of all, is
primary debris, secondary debris is like
shrapnel, it’s like  protect
all glass and
this material already from secondary fragments. It was for driving in our
internal tests, it was for a large
body armor, we tested it on a bullet, that
is, in fact, it is
high molecular polyethylene, so it
looks, it is gathered on the side, there are
28-30 shawls and in fact such  materials.
It is very light and very flexible.
It is a helmet, which is actually the same
helmet that our
servicemen wear  under conditions that this is a very small
mind